let's talk about ron desantis let's talk
about the 2024 primary
the biggest signal yet
that ron desantis plans to run for
president in 2024
regardless of whether trump is a
candidate is that desantis is now
holding
uh fundraisers with republican mega
donors and it's very clear what the plan
is here
i mentioned this yesterday and i said we
would delve into it more deeply today if
the republican mega donors say to
desantis
if you run in 24
we will support you rather than trump
that gives desantis the confidence to go
up against trump in a contested primary
one of the things that has infuriated
trump about desantis is that over the
last year when asked
would you only run
if trump doesn't
will you rule out a run if trump does
want the nomination desantis has
declined to make that promise he's just
said i just haven't made a decision yet
i haven't i haven't decided yet
and now desantis is doing a major
fundraiser cnbc reporting florida
governor ron desantis plans utah
fundraiser with republican mega donors
signaling possible presidential run yeah
you you do that if you're thinking of
running for president florida governor
ron desantis is planning a private
fundraiser in utah with some of the
country's wealthiest republican donors
desantis hasn't publicly ruled out a run
for president in 24 even if it means
challenging trump desantis spokeswoman
lindsey kernut wouldn't confirm any
details saying the campaign doesn't
discuss private fundraising events with
members of the press
this is going to be next week the week
of july 18th
many of the attendees asked not to be
identified because the campaign is
trying to keep the private event from
getting too much public attention
desantis is coming to utah to raise
money for his 2022 gubernatorial
re-election campaign fundraisers in
far-flung states like utah more than 2
000 miles from florida where desantis is
actually a candidate right now often
suggests
national aspirations so the next
question is
what does the polling look like desantis
hasn't said he's running and trump
hasn't said that he's running well we
have recent data um polling republican
primary polling and it sort of looks
okay for ron desantis considering he
hasn't announced anything yet uh polls
uh okay
morning consult from a few days ago
trump 52 desantis 21. now understand
trump's up 30.
desantis
is not a former president desantis is
not nearly as well known as trump not
even not even marginally as well known
as trump uh and desantis hasn't
announced anything and he's already
polling 21
uh from a few days prior new york times
sienna college poll has desantis with 25
again trump plus 24.
a few days earlier the courageous
conservatives pack poll
has a lot of undecideds and and other
candidates but has trump 38 to santa 17
that's only a 21 point margin for
desantis and then um a poll at the end
of june as well from harvard university
harris
um
desantis uh doing significantly better
than pence despite pence being the
former of vice president so that's
interesting the polling numbers don't
look bad for desantis despite desantis
having taken no moves yet and then maybe
more importantly at this early stage
when you allow people to bet money on
who they believe will be the nominee
sometimes you get
more forward-looking data or information
and if you look at the betting markets
right now
there is only a seven cent difference
and i'll explain what that means between
donald trump and ron desantis this is
not who will you support
this is
bet money who will win the 2024
republican presidential nomination
um when it comes to trump you have to
bet 42 cents to make a dollar
and when it comes to ron desantis you
have to bet 35 cents to make a dollar
that means it is seen as only slightly
less likely
that desantis will be the nominee than
trump those are incredible numbers this
far out particularly considering that
desantis hasn't announced anything now
trump hasn't either but as i said trump
is much more well known and donald trump
also um uh
is
talking about running in a way that that
ron desantis isn't also relevant nobody
else is even in the picture i mean
you've got nikki haley pence glenn
younkin mike pompeo ted cruz tim scott
just pennies pennies pennies on the
dollar so the truth is if desantis wants
this it's not a guarantee that he could
win but he will be a player for sure and
if he gets that republican mega donor
support if the republican mega donors
kind of you know give him the old wink
wink and say
if you were to run
we would be eager to support an
alternative to what we've done in the
past i think desantis is very very well
positioned